hey guys I wanted to create a quick
video on a question then someone had
about having less bowel movements when
they did in a minute fasting was that
normal okay so here's the short answer
to that when you're eating less food
less frequently you don't need to go as
often okay that's the simplicity of it
when you're eating more frequent you're
gonna have to go more because you're
just the volume of food now there's a
difference between constipation and just
having less bowel movements okay
constipation is when you really feel
like you're bloated and backed up you
need to go but you can't go okay versus
having a less balanced which you don't
even feel you need to go you just don't
go as frequent so if you feel
constipated or backed up it's probably
related to either consuming too many
vegetables or not enough vegetables okay
the microbes live on the fiber so if
you're not doing enough vegetables
increase it so they can have more food
and help you with your digestion if it's
too many vegetables okay which is
another possibility you that you're not
used to digesting especially certain
types like the cruciferous like cabbage
and broccoli and things that you're
probably not used to that can do it as
well because you don't have the microbes
to break them down because the microbes
have the enzymes break it down and so it
just kind of sits there in which case
you would want to change the type of
vegetable that you're consuming to
something that you can digest
I also recommend steaming your
vegetables and having some that are
fermented okay very important the last
thing I want to mention is if you don't
have a gallbladder or you have a
congestive gallbladder that means that
you don't have enough bile bile
lubricates the colon so you may need to
get some support with that and usually
the symptoms of lack of bile would be
your stool floats you get a full
sensation over the right lower ribcage
area that can refer to the right
shoulder burping belching bloating gas
okay so there's something called gall
bladder formula I put a link down below
to check it out but that will help you
lubricate the colon it has additional
things in there to help with the
pancreas
stomach so it's it'll help you if this
is the situation all right all right
thanks for watching so I want to know
what you're interested in as far as a
future video click the link down below
and share some ideas I want to hear